That's the case in general.
If you have N inputs, and K outputs,
you have (N+1)K parameters to use.
Not one more.
The thing is, you might want to use
many, many more parameters in practice.
Also, it's linear.
This means that the kind of interactions
that you're capable of representing with
that model is somewhat limited.
For example, if two inputs
interact in an additive way,
your model can represent them
well as a matrix multiply.
But if two inputs interact in the way
that the outcome depends on the product
of the two for
example, you won't be able to model
that efficiently with a linear model.
Linear operations
are really nice though.
Big matrix multiplies are exactly
what GPUs were designed for.
They're relatively cheap and
very, very fast.
Numerically linear
operations are very stable.
We can show mathematically that
small changes in the input
can never yield big
changes in the output.
The derivates are very nice too.
The derivative of a linear
function is constant.
You can't get more stable
numerically than a constant.
So, we would like to keep our parameters
inside big linear functions, but
we would also want the entire
model to be nonlinear.
We can't just keep multiplying
our inputs by linear functions,
because that's just equivalent
to one big linear function.
So, we're going to have to
introduce non-linearities.